i can already i can already hear
the sh the clacking knees of the youtube
uh band agents or moderators with their
fingers over the band button shaking
saying sing the wrong thing we're gonna
ban your show
because we're about to talk about
something big project veritas reports
military documents about gain of
function contradict fouchy testimony
under oath
military documents state that eco health
alliance approached darpa in march 2018
seeking funding to conduct gain of
function research of bat born
coronaviruses the proposal named project
defuse was rejected by darpa over safety
concerns and the notion that it violates
the gain of function research moratorium
the main report regarding the eco health
alliance proposal leaked on the internet
a couple months ago
it has remained unverified until now
project veritas has obtained a separate
report to the inspector general of the
department of defense written by u.s
marine corps major joseph murphy a
former darpa fellow
the proposal does not mention or assess
potential risks of gain of function
research a direct quote from the darpa
rejection letter project veritas reached
out to darpa for comment regarding the
the hidden documents and spoke with the
chief of communications jared adams who
said quote it doesn't sound normal to me
when asked about the way the documents
were buried
now i want to say a few things before we
get started very simply
consult your doctor and don't take any
of this as medical advice we're not here
to provide that and take it all with a
grain of salt i've seen a lot of people
jump on this and and say i see two
things one the left saying
you can't trust project veritas their
information is no good and that
therefore it's bad i see people on the
right saying this is definitive proof
it's finally what we're looking for let
me just state
this reporting by veritas very well done
very very well done veritas didn't just
come out and release a letter from an
arm from a marine corps major assessing
certain information and then claim and
then trying to claim it's true they
actually got corroborating evidence of a
of an intercept story this is from
september 23rd 2021 leaked grant
proposal details high-risk chronovirus
research where they specifically mention
project diffuse
which project veritas has now
corroborated this this is a left-wing
publication and project veritas getting
documents on the same thing suffice it
to say the left's assessment of project
veritas being wrong is untrue that being
said the the the assessment from the
major uh the us marine corps major is
just that it is his analysis of
undisclosed documents
trust them if you want to trust them or
don't i think it's very important to to
make sure that
you take into consideration it's not
someone involved in the projects
admitting to anything it's someone who
had been at darpa saying i read these
documents and here's my analysis that
being said i don't know luke if you want
to start bringing up some of these
points that you thought were most
alarming yeah i mean if these documents
are true i mean there's a lot of big
implications here because this shows how
echo health alliance was seeking darpa
funding in specific gain of function
research related to bat coronaviruses
they called this project diffuse and
allegedly according to these documents
this was rejected by darpa in 2018
because of safety concerns and it would
violate a lot of of course uh the
protections that are in the united
states that don't allow this kind of
dangerous work which could lead to some
very serious ramifications what did niid
do what that echo health alliance do
after this they just simply said well
there's no regulations and safety
concerns in china where the chinese
government gets to do whatever they want
as long as they oversee every step of
the process and essentially i think it's
fair to assume now that they took this
very dangerous work which allegedly
according to these documents darpa
didn't want to do because it was too
dangerous it was too unsafe and just
they just did it in china
which proved that there was some warning
some hindsight here that that should be
of course known about that should be
talked about there was also u.s senator
rand paul questioning
dr faucia about a lot of this there's
also the the gop oversight committee
releasing the emails and the
communications with niad specifically
showing how dr fauci is being accused of
concealing about a lot of the origin of
this story coming from that wuhan
laboratory with where this dangerous
function studies were being sent to and
downplaying this lab leak theory
that's big we had a it was peter navarro
who was on the show and he said that
at the time they were having these
meetings about covet and this potential
pandemic fauci was there and did not
disclose to them the things he had known
about gain of function about ecohealth
alliance and even if they didn't believe
the lab leak theory or hypothesis or
whatever don't you think fauci should
have told the trump administration hey
there's something we considered and it's
this that it may have come from this lab
you would you would think that if that
administrative state answered to the
executive branch which apparently i'm
learning in my adult years that it
doesn't necessarily uh it doesn't
necessarily play
second fiddle to the the executive
branch what i'm saying is the
administrative
state the deep these people that have
been there for 40 years fauci been in
that job for 40 years
he doesn't answer to joe biden highest
paid government employee right yep and
then 132 000 is that a salary uh yep
that's that's a huge amount of i got
actually for a government worker i got
to read a portion of this analysis
because i'm not going to look i
understand that um
this can be considered contentious so
i'm going to read this portion from the
defense advanced research projects
agency document from commandant of the
marine corps fellow at darpa to the
inspector general subject sars kovi ii
origins investigation with the u.s
government program
undisclosed document analysis that right
there is very important to consider
this is somebody who worked at darpa who
read the following documents and is
providing his analysis
but his analysis is absolutely insane
okay and and you can take that any
direction you want someone on the left
is going to be like this dude's out of
his mind and people on the writer be
like yo this is crazy
in the more colloquial sense
he says
you ready for this
sars cov2
is an american-created recombinant bat
vaccine or its precursor virus it was
created by an eco health alliance
program at the wuhan institute of
virology as suggested by the reporting
surrounding the lab leak hypothesis the
details of this program have been
concealed since the pandemic began these
details can be found in the eco health
alliance proposal response to the darpa
pre-empt program broad agency
announcement dated march 2018 a document
not yet publicly disclosed the contents
of the proposed program are extremely
detailed
peter dashik lays out step by step what
the organization intends to do by phase
and by location the primary scientists
involved their roles and their
institutions are indicated the funding
plan for the wiv work is its own
document the reasons why
non-pharmaceutical interventions like
masks and medical countermeasures like
mrna vaccines do not work well can be
extrapolated from the details the
reasons why the early treatment
protocols work as curatives are apparent
now that is where
you start to get into danger zone
territory but let me just i want to make
sure it's very clear
this is this is a major at darpa
giving his assessment of these documents
now this is an expert i mean this is a
guy who's privy to information that was
not publicly disclosed talking about
what he thinks about it that being said
take it with a grain of salt you've got
to decide for you what you think is is
uh you know what what's trustworthy and
what's not and i will very much add as
it pertains to what he's saying that is
the opinion of this major not the show
it is not medical advice and always
consult a trusted medical professional
on your medical decisions and and what
needs to happen for you and i'll just
keep it you know i'll leave it there
yeah i mean this is his assessment after
looking at some of the classified
information that the public is not privy
to i think right now the conversation
has been started and for the government
to clear everything up here to have some
transparency and accountability they
should release these documents
immediately so they could set the record
straight specifically so we know exactly
what's going on here you want us to
trust us give us reason to give us these
documents release them the time is now
more than ever to do so i'm weary a
little bit i'm wary you know i don't
think i i think uh project veritas has
released the other diffused documents
which is corroborating reporting we got
a few months ago and i think that was
smart it shows that these additional
documents they receive do come from a
verified source
however many people have pointed out
doesn't this seem a little too good to
be true like too on the nose a better
way to play uh maybe but also it's kind
of like the emperor is not wearing any
clothes you guys
uh duh we've thought this maybe that
there was a lab leak going on for like i
don't know eight months it's starting to
be well more accepted or five months or
six months well just really now it's
like
uh okay just don't ban me for pointing
out that the emperor has no clothes for
a second but this this could be a psy
but we're going to talk about that in
just a little bit no no for sure it
might be invisible clothes yeah this
could be a psyop perhaps we know that
there were attempts to provide false
documents to wikileaks in the past
tricking them into publishing them so
they could then say aha look wikileaks
publishes false information
but i also want to point out could it be
that this major
read the same news sources or watch
tucker carlson and then wrote a report
based on what he saw in the news it
could be fabricated yeah not fabricated
just like you know he says um what does
he say uh he actually mentions in in the
article as reported you know
oh
uh the lab leak hypothesis as reporter
whatever he says right so you think it
might be partisan like political or
traumatic not necessarily political but
you know his view you know it it's it's
tough out of sight out of mind and and
the opposite right if people
don't hear something in the news they
don't talk about it if people do hear
the news they talk about it i'm just
saying it's possible that this guy may
have just it may sound like a bit on the
nose because maybe he's getting for all
we know this guy watches this show
and then he's like wow that's crazy then
he writes a report he reads the document
says yep i see it and then we then end
up reading it being like aha and it's
just confirming you know what we what we
already believed well i i agree with you
on the timing of this this does seem a
little bit suspicious to me because all
of this all of these jake tapper is
starting to agree with these crazy
right-wing conspiracies they're
admitting that like the menstrual
changes that women were reporting that
they said was nonsense all this is
happening at the same time very
convenient yeah so that's a good point
we've got
npr
saying yes actually the vaccines do
alter your menstrual cycle something
women had been saying for the past
couple of years that was deemed a
conspiracy theory then you get jake
tapper outraged that covet
hospitalizations are inflated by some 40
percent then we get this document
basically giving giving an expert
confirmation or an expert analysis which
lends itself to lab leak hypothesis that
does smell like a psyop to me they were
actually i don't want to outright say
it's discredited numbers would have been
inflated by 60
if 40 of them were
of the total had been inflated that
means when you have 60 is your full
amount to get to 100 you're gonna have
to increase it by 40 which is 60 of 60
thereabout so it's actually inflating
the number by it's a little not
necessarily kind of a derailment but
they inflated the numbers by 60 to get
to a place where it says that forty
percent of them
uh didn't had had comorbidities and well
so they've even basically no no the
inflation was when they said that people
with kovid
instead of from kovitz yeah that's new
york state announcing that with the
governor officially saying there was a
really funny tweet i retweeted someone
said is um is american democracy dying
with covet or from copenhagen and i was
like that's actually that was a really
really good one yeah but uh yeah in this
instance with jake tapper the issue is
someone bumps their head goes to the
hospital they say we're going to test
you for kovid
when when i had kovid and i called the
local hospital i was like what's the
protocol like what should i do and they
said why don't you come in and i said
okay well what do i do if i come in they
said we'll run some tests and i said why
would i need tests done like i took an
at-home test it said i had covid and
they were like well we'll come in and
we'll do some tests and then i i kid you
not that's and i said and then what do
you do for me are you gonna prescribe
medicine i said no and i said so i
should just like leave my home and come
here so you can tell me what i already
know
should i i was like i was calling
because i was wondering if there was
like a if if there was something you can
do or if there's something i should do
and they're like oh no it's a virus go
to sleep and uh okay
but they wanted me i i swear so
afterwards i was like they want me to
just come in for tests is it because
they're they want to just run billing
they get paid baby we were talking about
that yesterday how much money these
organizations are getting for having a
coveted case having a cove of death on a
file on ventilators putting people on
ventilators and that's just on file with
covid on file and then it's treated as
as it was a covid thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to watch live you can check
out this channel monday through friday
at 8 00 pm and don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel and if you want more unfiltered
and uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time